so the first question comes in is Jason
who wrote in to say he has a fear of
failure how do I get over my fear of
failure what do you think Stephen you
know unless some god I look at myself
Tommy every week I I probably fail at
something I think it's a really good
point I think as human beings the way we
kind of indoctrinated by the education
systems all about passing exams and
perfection a NASA not real life that's
not business business is all about
making log state and one one man trying
to use internally yrics ages fell fast
learn quickly and also I kind of think
because of the fear of failure people
spend way too much time building fancy
business plans that never see the light
of day or over-engineering crazy
strategies and fancy diagrams and stuff
as if they're you know G or someone like
that you're much better test drive and
getting into execution fading fast
course correction find out and again you
know the world you've really kind of
capture this ever around social media
you can find out in nanoseconds customer
reaction and therefore you can involve
your product strategy in minutes so I
kind of think the whole essence of great
business is great stone arts of people
who fell fast and I've got passion
around learning and improvement I love
it I would add that I think think people
see failure as this big huge negative
thing you should avoid where it's it's
just part of the process if you try to
do something and avoid any kind of
failure than your plane it's so safe
that that you're never going to
accomplish your goal and so failure is
not the enemy it's just making sure you
don't fail huge right you're gonna fail
a lot along your weight think about
anything that you learned right you you
wrote a bike you fell down you learn to
ski you fell down you learn French you
made mistakes like failure is just part
of the process you can't avoid it it's
just understanding that you're using
that that leverage
you've learned to then make your product
your service your business better and so
just bail fast feel smarter feel smaller
so that you can get to where you want to
go and so don't fear failure because
it's going to happen and I think just
understanding that might relieve some of
the pressure like you don't have to be
perfect as perfect doesn't exist and
fairly what happened along the way to
you achieving your goal yeah yeah test
drive often you know test drive you talk
about riding the bike but in your car
getting your license you have to test
drive yeah in business you have to
absolutely and it probably every month
every you you need to be reinvented
himself hopefully the world we live in
particular social readers about tweaks
today from customers saying guys you
could do a better job that is the best
feedback like a nap every day I live and
die by taking feedback and changing the
course in terms of the service
composition all the products or whatever
it is we're out there doing so I think
kind of directly dew point evidence is
something which would probably train
through the kind of education systems
are negative I see is a really massive
positive